[Music]
hello army hello
I Greg monster and I'm John Cooke I wear
this friend's shirt
Central Perk in representation of how my
rat monster learned and glossy oh that
is Spanish for English and I'm wearing
this amoeba music t-shirt because I
assume you can purchase BTS albums there
it's the one group you can't get music
from oh wow
that's messed up guys we're gonna watch
a very short video hmm it's 37 seconds
well when this came out this was the
most talked about thing I saw on social
media even for people who don't know BTS
or like who's what BTS intro persona boy
the melon what does it called Melon
Music Award Melon Music Awards I should
have picked it up it said mm eh
yeah mixed martial arts where BTS
performed the mixed martial arts awards
some people are calling this the
performance of the year of a lifetime
will decide oh yeah yes
will this side guys on our patreon page
we got a bunch of [ __ ] but what I wanted
to tell you one Humphrey huh he does
music video reactions weekly so go check
it out uncut uncensored this might be
cut up circumcised because sometimes
they get blocked
oh yeah and this is the top reward to
your video request from none other than
the hottie from Ireland Natalie Duran oh
right just like that she fell in love
with you was dude haha
no subs couldn't find any subs but I
learned Korean just for this video yeah
they're coming out coming out what gonna
wake him up go wake him up for the show
I heard when they wake up they do start
dancing the dance around about wake up
mr. West
[Music]
I'm ready for the [ __ ] I'm ready for the
[ __ ] I'm ready for this ship ready for
this I want to buy a Kia now for some
reason
oh my god
your shadows are getting away from you
they're like interdimensional beings
they're able to right now oh I get it
they're meditating and their spirits are
there hi mm-hmm that's what I'll smoke
sure on drugs map of the soul
[Music]
[Music]
damn [ __ ]
[Music]
you go
[Music]
there is nothing like these guys huh
[Music]
that's not visual-effects dancehall him
it's always soul coming
literally any little movement of thing
they do the crowd loses those whoa
[Music]
[Music]
Oh wanna throw my panties at stade right
now can he meet his fans only through
the BTS world app like like you just did
like killed by accident trampled by love
might be right here I'm right here yeah
ah he couldn't help but smile look happy
my boy jungkook's got that red in his
hair
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I want my hair like this I could be done
[Music]
[Music]
got all that Chris yeah Teleca
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know they do all this without vocal
warm-ups and no stretching huh
I'd never spell
[Music]
dan they give them like nearly 40
minutes at a freakin words oh god yeah
like they gonna keep this up for 40
minutes man at a concert they gotta do
it for over now I do okay all right
television Jesus Christ
I love it so just like he knows his
sexual allure so much
[Music]
are me
[Music]
I want you all of you
[Music]
oh hell yeah
ah boy with nerve
[Music]
how much take it's harder this event you
go next year like 20 $20 yeah 25:34 a
front of line yes we want to won't be
there one day oh yeah I'm talking about
[Music]
Shaco just looks like he's having a
blast
he's always started smiling you know
he's just having fun
[Music]
[Music]
it's just great sounding music man mmm
magic
music this is crazy like you don't even
need to know what the lyrics are I'd
like Merida hots up just like it's just
like the emotion just really clicks
[Music]
[Music]
I love them so much I signed up to join
the army really going to the army to
start soon you mentioned I served four
years for you
[Music]
I want all their famous success about
all the hard work it takes to get it
yeah yeah overnight yeah
[Music]
[Music]
my idea again
[Music]
he's talking directly to me
no it's talking to me so we started me
hungry me
[Music]
ah kick
[Music]
once in a minute go fight yes seven
other people yeah well I'm sure there's
another seven piece band at the show
take it out against
[Music]
the official like ending signal food you
know that stain cooks super finger don't
get a good pass right
[Music]
[Music]
got to a hundred years later Tex
that's probably the most impressive
skill it's just a layer like they whip
the suits off and these are
actually they're all wearing a one-piece
they're all during the bad casas digital
animators are putting the clothes on
life where's my camera imagine it they
get an eight-member one day oh yeah who
could it be them so you could be like
their height buoyant yeah jump around do
some kicks you know they don't need the
high voice no one of them just needs to
like move a finger and everyone I do
like that Wow
BTS universe right that's what happens
with download yeah yeah this is all just
an app promotion augments video you can
project it is around your own house
everyone go
[Laughter]
[Music]
holy crap
where are they standing the middle the
universe Greg their rightful place
[Music]
are they on the same state as everyone's
make a different color
yeah I think they're all in the same
platform this is just an elaborate CGI
so why does it crazy nuts every asana
beat it yeah kind of it this is nice for
then we get a break it's they're all
hooked up to IVs right now just can't
see yeah
[Music]
ich liebe dich dick
Penda
Eskimo
Legg elsker dead literally pulled out
just 45 random words ha ha ha
[Music]
I would do half of them they're lower
half
ah that's one shy of a full sausage back
to such a just coming back the tents
nice
or eight
[Music]
that's a boner when this song comes out
everyone it was uh wow look at that
very relaxed methods they're really
gonna make in like their BTS universe
fandom feel United like we're all a part
of it
a squeezer go inaudible ng
so watch they've been there the whole
time guys last year's no no
[Music]
what if or they were just like I don't
like that this o come o come Emmanuel
huh
think so it's Christmas I suppose
look at those dreamy eyes the perfect
skin
I'll never have as good of eyes Dionysus
[Music]
you like that guy could've pantomime
one thousand people audition
[Music]
whoa
after all about universe and love we're
marching in a battle in ancient Rome
[Laughter]
hey man major credit to the cameraman at
the ship dude yes here's the laQuan
everybody who's all the people behind
the scenes like running these lights and
not enough [ __ ] that the cameraman is
now I roll my bald in this show
[Music]
what epic flames of this one right
[Music]
Oh No
I guess they're weak
the Trojan horse
for the BTS members hiding inside that
or probably yeah
or maybe it's members of like a
different k-pop group come to start a
fight yeah
we're gonna love to see BTS star in the
next Troy adaptation yes yes all of them
can play Achilles Oh spirit stallion of
the salon
somebody saw frozen - yeah yeah yeah
what they send a real horse is
stampeding through those
goddamn I am that horse Wow whoa Wow
oh hell yeah oh my god I love this kind
of dancing I really do oh yes oh hell
yeah I didn't know oh man you didn't
know he could dance and it is this kind
of dances is great yeah I love watching
these
[Music]
wowie
[Music]
Wow Oh House on the verge of tears right
oh Jesus
[Music]
[Music]
like it no I am NOT the amount of like
moving reset screams Wow
fire
wonder if any of the music backing music
is live drums kind of sound bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no wow
oh yeah nice
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
fun fact most of their fanbase
Republicans was that common really
necessary - yes yes it was huge in
Alabama oh my god a dark angel he's the
son of God
yes what that was all about was the holy
water
[Music]
[Music]
do you not get hit by a the lasers guys
who get cut in half since I'm resident
[Music]
oh so sexy yeah tell me
oh nice
[Music]
goddamn the variety in this and this one
performance yeah crazy
[Music]
you haven't seen me for a while because
I was putting this off let me go hang a
portrait of myself in the Attic I was
gonna do my aging for me
[Music]
he's gonna walk out
[Music]
well
[Music]
[Music]
everyone get on your phone so you won't
be able to watch us anywhere else but a
memory on your phone oh wow
they're all in there Wow do you see it
[Music]
every other person haha have you winked
[Music]
she was fired that very night for
winking at the camera holy BTS you
unprofessional [ __ ] this is the most
spectacular suits god I want to kill you
so bad you want to what IKEA keep
advertising cheap
[Music]
Oh goddamn
[Music]
those private detectives yes we're here
to investigate a murder reenact see for
the last eight minutes spell real horses
they're gonna ride them in the crowd
just like I wanted that's right crowd
surfing on a horse 13 people died horse
jumping on top of them
[Music]
this crazy-ass production design this is
nuts
this yeah this is a whole variety show
of its own
not even the Super Bowl is the
spectacular their performances I know
this is insane
I think we need left shark and right
shark in this videos being super comp
that's all this needs is a left shark
and a right shark from the Super Bowl oh
yeah when of beats yes gonna play the
Super Bowl halftime
[Music]
it's relegated it lasts eight minutes
just gonna write it out bed just sit
here now entertain us while we eat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take a little that one over that move
[Music]
[Music]
there should be like a dance central but
just BTS oh dude yes comedy no one can
passive yeah way too complicated yeah
there should be like a singing game or
you need seven people
[Music]
one thing I can guarantee about these
guys they do not smoke weed yes and
they're like the super illegal there's
no way they can stand that the memory
underground rap yeah
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
whoa
huh
[Music]
Wow
carefully they improvise all this I know
they weren't even supposed to perform Oh
No
what
there is
[Music]
oh damn
[Music]
Oh goddamn I think it's hard yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow they took a 30 minute power nap
after that hey Cyril fell asleep on the
spot oh that was a religious experience
that they have to get him like those
lost in space tanks oversleep oh yeah it
was like right over there freeze
chambers 30 minutes I'm refreshed they
gonna sleep for 30 minutes at night
mm-hm they are so efficient that they
you know boiled it down to the most
effective foams and I've heard their
vacations are six hours off once a year
oh yeah on a specific Saturday but they
get a lot done on those vacations they
get all their relaxing oh you know that
they're just working in a nicer location
I cannot believe what we just watched
I'll admit thirty seven minute video her
we were gonna watch and I thought it was
just gonna be them you know singing and
dancing on stage
it sure would be entertaining his yeah
absolutely but then we got it for all
whole other things this kept going
because you start off with just RM
rapping in what they want to look like a
ghetto area yeah it's like a rundown
classroom yeah and then he's rapping and
then they get on stage and they do their
thing well we kind of expected suddenly
we're in the universe then we're in some
type of not Roman oh it's Greek great
times the Greek times that were in
heaven and then we're at a hell there
were somewhere in between and we're at
some kind of like banquet last supper
table and it just kept going their
ability of performance is so impressive
yeah I mean I get what people call this
performance of the year this is one of
the best live performances I've ever
seen
hands down generally speaking this makes
me want to go catches our next show
whenever they come to town again is
there all this but I don't know but like
they do arena tours now even Natalie who
requested this video I think saw them at
like Wembley Stadium or Brixton Academy
or something
I bet their live shows are pretty
spectacular and pretty dazzling as well
as these awards all of the awards are
proud
a little more gussied how they do this I
never understand these superhuman they
are the equivalent of superheroes in my
mind I don't know how they can possibly
keep up with how much you've got to
remember seven minutes how do you
properly prepared for all this in the
middle of everything else they're
already doing yeah you take a month off
just to prepare for the melon music
course gosh
it's insane then and to be that in sync
seven of them and then on top of that
too yeah like all the backup dancers all
the back of performers production
designs a set designers everyone
coordinating backstage of what has to go
down who has to go where change your
wardrobe here the amount of directing
and the guys in the booth opera like cut
to the barricade the camera operators
everything it's it's it's such a
well-oiled machine all centered around
them and they're crazy production with a
fire yeah could not believe what I was
watching this is the most insane thing
I've ever seen from a live performance
in 37 minutes flew by I know I mean I'm
still astonished that they got this much
time I I mean I'm sure whoever produces
the show knows that that will definitely
bring in viewers but it's a testament to
their to their status in the world that
they got to take up so much of this and
it is so spectacular and it even had
like a variance of dance styles because
I mean we're used to seeing them doing
their synchronised thing but you also
had the bit with the shroud and the bit
with the water as well which I thought
were two really cool sort of more
traditional and a different Lane of
dance yeah I appreciated them working
into this
yeah the imagery the costuming that
whole thing with the galaxies like they
made it clearly special for the people
watching but also special for us
watching here because I'm sure that
galactic effect was pretty visit X heavy
I just want to go to the gym and like
run on a treadmill and walk on a
high-end client oh I see I mean I'm sure
that's part of what they do is they
probably sing while on treadmills or on
you know exercise machines if there's
one thing I've come to terms with John I
will never be you could do it don't know
yourself short you never ever have any
level of tappers you know the broker
there's a kpop sensibility to entire
Philippine
community perfectly content sitting here
absorbing them through a computer you
know you're missing out especially mr.
dance central over here come on I'll
tell you if I met all seven in person
I'd be the first man to be the
equivalent of the Virgin Mary become
pregnant a punt eye contact you have a
baby bump the second you shake one of
their hands it would just be conceived
of them and all seven there's been this
one child the most beautiful baby I tell
you it'll be the son of BTS oh the for
the chosen wine the chosen one you are
the chosen want to be the equivalent of
all of them it's gonna be nuts it's
gonna be insane and I will have fathered
that child a man that's if that's your
legacy if that's your destiny on this
year planner I'm okay with that I think
it's a worthy yeah I mean it's an honor
probably to be chosen out of that buy it
buy them when that child asked me who
those parent whose parents are I'm gonna
say there were nobody there nobody
something jobs to make a Star Wars
reference hmm I bet they like Star Wars
I wonder if they're upset about the I
wonder if they hated the last Jedi or if
they appreciated the the branching out
of the Star Wars these guys can do
literally nothing and the crowd loses
their [ __ ] oh yeah they can get on stage
and play one of their songs through
their iPhone not hook up to a speaker
just hold it down they don't even have
to put on the mic hold it up you can
barely a pickup of audio from it they're
here
just at all how many people just just
faint seeing them at a show and if
you'll just faint sure a few how do you
become lightheaded from the amount of
the yelling video I'm gonna I'm gonna
say an average of six people a show 60%
of the audience all padded at these
shows and their medics standing by with
orange juice and crackers to get
everybody back on their pledge
I mean nuts yeah alright guys well what
did you think of this performance do you
think it's the performance of the year
lifetime subscribe to the rail rejects
subscribe to bangtan TV subscribe to
bangtan TV so I love your RM impression
just try and do it every time yeah we'll
see is his confident American check us
out on patreon where John is doing stuff
and Natalie Doran thank you so much for
requesting this my dear it's talking
with her recently oh she would like to
travel during the holidays unfortunately
she can't oh because work and stuff
she'll be taking another trip later on
in June to Florida so that means John
gonna be liking her bikini photos only
and I'll be looking over a distance
going can I do
no I mustn't look I'm message and then
you'll try and you know kill me out of
resentment and then you know well she's
been going through like a lot of
weddings lately I mean she's looking
great when are you gonna get married
I asked her that yeah she said she's 12
she can and I was like oh [ __ ] we should
have talked to you the way how do you
have a youtube account she's 22 and so
she's got years ahead of her but I know
she's really trying to say she's waiting
for BTS to hit her up once she gets that
BTS group orgy going then she could
finally find true love get that out of
her system find true love I know the way
you roll Natalie yeah not fake love no
I'd be true love
love to be Thank You Natalie